we have succeeded something very
significant today and it is not the case
in my personal experience to remember
that council members will welcome
passing the decision with applause but
it happened today today council of
justice ministers established European
Public Prosecutor's Office the figure of
money European citizens taxpayers will
lose from corruption from EU funds is
150 billion euros and we need to deliver
a clear solution to fight that and
European Public Prosecutor's Office is
that solution indeed we had a very
productive day today and I find this day
to be a historic day because we managed
after several years to come to a final
moment of adoption of the European
Prosecutor's Office we have 20 member
states on board we hope and we believe
others will come later of soon or sooner
and we want to deploy the best people
for this new institution which should
come with real change in combating
financial crime in the EU we need to see
the benefits of the PPO as soon as
possible as soon after it starts working
starts working in 2020 we also spoke
about freezing and confiscation proposal
it was an important debate about the
scope and also a Crist cert country
Nationals proposal was debated we need
to work more on this very important file
which belongs to the key priorities for
security in Europe I hope we will get it
right and put forward this important
file as soon as possible